The autism flat,
and I do think that it is accurate to
say that the information technology
industry made other countries,
particularly the United States recognize
the changes that had taken place in
India and recognize the potential
because of course it was for some time
the largest,
uh,
exchange between India and the United
States was in the IT industry.
And of course this is not only because
we are on opposite sides of the globe.
So,
uh,
you know,
the day or night factor plays very
nicely for walk in both countries,
but also because a fairly large number
of Indian origin Americans in Silicon
Valley,
we're making their mark.
They were part of the innovative ideas
that were germinating in the silicon
valley.
They were part of the way the connection
was made between Bangalore and the
Silicon Valley.
And so,
uh,
I think that maybe the recognition by
the,
uh,
by the,
United States came as the relationship
in ICT expanded.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think that there are lots of other
areas in which as well we have the
institute for Economic Exchange.